parent like yeah there's a whole
generation of women that are just
terrible mothers yeah and I don't get it
yeah well it's because we've been told
we live in this Society where they just
tell us the only thing that matters is
us and our feelings haven't you ever
heard like women saying like leaving on
Tick Tock talking about they left to
find themselves to be happy that I
outgrew him yeah those are all stupid
reasons to leave America it is it is I
left my lost relationship because as I
said in the last podcast I'm pretty sure
I felt like it was all about him I was
like well I need to leave to be able to
do what I wanted to do and like I still
support him in what he does but I was
like I need to move on to be able to
grow as a person I've grown I have grown
so much well and I got